hey lebron coach volkl was talking about
you guys know what toronto was going to
do defensively packing the paint
not fouling and forcing you to hit shots
if shots aren't going down
as a team like tonight what are some
things that you guys can do better to be
more efficient on that
i don't think there's anything you can
do better um you execute your offense
you get the best shot
and we did that tonight we went 10 for
40 from the three-point line
i believe a lot of those uh 40 those
threes are great looks wide open clips
after getting into the paint knowing
what they're going to give up then we
just have to step up and knock them down
you know so um and i don't think there's
anything that you can do better i mean i
think we defended
a very uh very good offensive uh
team and the raptors but we got to make
shots and uh when you make shots and
loosen up the defense
and we didn't do it enough tonight frank
said he thought part of that could just
be that if you're playing really hard
defensively and you thought you guys
were
maybe some of the legs aren't there at
this point is that just
getting more game reps so you guys have
been on for a while and trying to ramp
up to that point until the playoff start
i don't know i think that's a it could
be uh that's an individual question to
every individual
uh for me personally my ladies feel
pretty good
um you know and i was just i'm just
trying to put the ball on time on target
trying to run the offense trying to get
my shots as well so
um you know we've been out for for a
while um
you know and i think the game likes to
continue to come um you know as the
as this um you know this ae tournament
continues to go on so
um i'm not i'm not you know too uh you
know too worried about that our shooters
shoot
and we got some great guys that can make
shots from the perimeter and they will
make them
hey lebron steve in the past you said
your patience is
one of your qualities that you need to
work on um
where is your patient at when it comes
to this restart process and
trying to manage where you guys are at
versus where you expect to be
well i think uh the only time would tell
i mean i don't
really have no expectations you know
right now
i think uh for us we want to continue to
get better and better
um use these eight games to try to gear
up for the postseason but this is a
different situation it's a different
circumstances you've been out four and a
half months
um and you hope that we could pick it
right back up but obviously it's going
to take some time
we also added two new guys it's going to
be in rotation you know with jr and dion
so they're learning
on the fly as well so um you know it's
all about the process it's all about
getting back in rhythm getting back into
timing and uh
you know go from there but you know
every game is opportunity for us to get
better i thought defensively were really
good tonight
i thought offensively we got some very
very good looks but they just didn't go
down so um
you know pretty pretty you know okay
with uh you know the way we perform
johnny how did you see amy
um he responded great um you know we got
guys great looks you know
it's a numbers game you know they put
two on the ball i mean there's a 403 on
the back side
and he continued to bait the defense and
uh got his teammates great looks
good oh you know what you guys are very
close to clinching the one seed in a
normal season maybe that would mean
lower minutes and
maybe some games where you sit out how
important do you think is of the
remaining six games
is it to play that out to make sure that
you guys get to where you want to get
competitively well obviously health as
well
you know that's the number one thing you
know and then chemistry comes with that
on the floor
uh so you know going into the postseason
as healthy as we can be after four and a
half months layoff is what's most
important
um you know clinching the one seed um
is there advantage here it's not much of
a it's not a home court advantage here
but
you know we worked hard to to be the
number one team in the west um
um you know possibly the number one team
in the league obviously milwaukee's
still playing this really well but
um you know we got this far so we might
as well try to figure it out and
you close it off the right way
joe barton please fine two
first there's a couple plays i think it
was late third maybe early fourth you
were out there
and there's corner threes and you're
upset there's nothing a miscommunication
what
what was it you guys there's a couple
times a couple corners reasons you're
upset that
they were wide open what was the
miscommunication
uh just in game it's all about in-game
adjustments in-game communication
uh we have some breakdowns and you're
asking this question
almost every year but because the
circumstances are so different
are you paying attention to the ranks
for the eighth seed and you're like the
first round opponent
was how that's all shaken up
um no not up until this point not up
until this point
um you know for me you know in this ball
club we try to get better every day
you know as much as when we on the court
we want to get better on the floor um
we have our film sessions we want to get
better film sessions um
but i'm not i'm not paying attention to
what's going down going on with the ac
right now uh because it's too much that
can happen and then there's
some playing games or whatever the case
may be to decide that so it's too far
far away tanya one follow-up
yeah um early in the fourth quarter you
hit a three and you kind of
as you were coming back down the court
you looked into the crowd
or like where the crowd would be and
like that's something you do during the
games but is it
was it disconcerting to look out there
and see people like rob was in the area
no no it's not uh i mean it's just when
you have routines and you you've been
doing it for so long
you're just used to that yesterday
routine and you're just trying to make
plays
um you know i was trying to you know put
myself in a
in a rolled environment you know this
was uh the raptors home game so
you know taking and making big shots on
the road floor is uh something that i
relish i love
you know playing on you know on the on
this floor so i'm just trying to have
that mindset you know going down and
stretching forward
hey lebron it's bill last two questions
i'm wondering this i mean this raptors
team has beaten you twice now
in kind of kind of similar ways and i'm
just wondering is there a kind of team
that is a i don't want to say a bad
matchup for you guys but a worse matchup
that gives you guys
the most trouble and what what kind of
what kind of how would you just
what is the team that would give you um
that kind of trouble well i think it's a
great team i mean they won a
championship for a reason
um you know and it's it wasn't just all
solely because of kawhi and obviously
you see that um
you know they got the two-headed
monsters and fred and kyle
and sets the tone and and they wings are
extremely
uh you know extremely good and pascal
and and
og and they got so much they got
experience in the front court
at the center position and mark and
serge and then they got a bunch of
complimentary guys and that's why
uh you know they've been the team that
they've been all year
us i feel like we played you know well
to beat them tonight we just didn't have
enough shots to go in and then they
executed and they hit some shots
you know that uh that we weren't able to
hit so
um you know sometimes it can't be a make
or miss league but um
you don't take enough you don't take any
credit uh away from uh from the raptors
they uh
last question dave mcmahon
[Music]
there we go hey lebron um a lot of
seasons the defending champ gets talked
about a lot more than this raptors team
has been talked about
obviously they had kawhi leonard changed
teams but
in terms of that conversation how do you
view that raptors
team that's a great team
air fans are bus um exceptionally well
coached
and um you know championship dna you can
never take that away from a ball club
you win a championship um and even
before that they just gotta play off
testing guys
you know guys have played not only um
here in the nba
and big games but also um in fifa games
as well
mark has been you know in big games
throughout his whole life
pretty much it seems like you know so
you know that's just a great team and um
you know the media may not
uh talk about them much or give them
much credit because kawhi is gone but
um players know that you definitely um
know what type of team now
appreciate it thank you thanks rj all
right we have 18 next
yes okay thanks hey anthony this isn't
the first time that a team has been
aggressive with you defensively
double teaming try to get the ball out
of your hands early what are the things
that you're
trying to look at and what are some of
the counters that you want to try to
employ
i'm just trying to find over god um you
know we knew that everybody on double
and you know just making the the right
reads um
you know unfortunately they shoot the
ball well tonight at all
um from the field orphan three which
kind of you know let them
you know continue with their game plan
with the devil in me
um i think rita made a couple shots uh
then it would have
definitely changed a little bit but they
had a good game plan coming in you know
don't
double-team me and get the ball out of
my hands and
you know live with us making shots
lebron said that legs at this point of
the season
it's just a unique case so every player
is a bit it's a bit different
wonder how you feel after these two
seating games following the scrimmage
games and all the time off
how do you feel as the playoffs are now
just a couple weeks away
uh how do i feel personally yeah yeah
just how do the legs feel personally
i feel good um you know i didn't get a
lot
a lot of time in the preseason um
because of the high but
you know i feel good i feel good playing
out there
um conditioning is fine so
i'm ready to keep going hey d
kind of melissa hey hey um kind of
playing off of the previous question
frank's about um a good amount of guys
reported soreness
after last game i'm curious after 142
days without playing a game
what it feels like to be back on the
court playing these intense type of
games
it was good to get some competition
there like i said i didn't get a chance
to play much in the preseason
so in the scrimmage games rather so i
felt great
um coming into that first game and even
tonight um
yeah i wasn't sure at all so
i had a couple more days rest in
everybody else
okay
were you uh been a couple of games
you've done a home game
and a road game here in this environment
um what is is it disconcerting to
you know that like if you look out into
the stands
i don't even pay attention to it
honestly um
it makes no difference to me uh i said
when i play
i don't worry about what's going on on
the floor um that's and that's
excuse me before you know hiatus i was
still
you know even at staples or on the road
someone else's arena i will always
just focus on the floor i don't hear
anything outside of that
um so this is kind of what
[Music]
[Music]
same obviously but um
you know they do a good job of clogging
the paint
uh i think they're like a second or
something in
you know defense um but they're 29th and
three-pointed billboard attempts
but you know 30 like percentage
defensively so
um they let god shoot the three but do a
great job of contesting and making guys
miss
um so they're great defensive team uh we
know it's gonna be a tough game coming
down you know obviously
you know they got us in la as well um
you know defending champion so um that's
awesome
last question dave mcmahon
hey anthony i know you like to judge
your guy's performance based on defense
and so even though
you lost and i only gave a 107 points
which is still you know
below the nba average when you move
forward
look to the utah game and look to the
rest of the seating round
can you take some solace in where the
defense is at
and and just feel like there'll be
enough time for the offense or how do
you view
where you guys are through two games
yeah i think our defense is there
uh we had some you know plays tonight
that kind of hurt us
um you know probably jump shooters by
the break points towards the end
you know messing up some coverages but i
think our
you know i think our defense is there i
think want where we want to be
defensively and
even if we play a little bit better
defensively tonight
um some of the things that we control
you know we
would probably help them you know less
than what
you know we gave them tonight so you
know i think our defense there
you know offense kind of struggled
tonight but um
you know i'm not too worried about our
offense you know it's a
you know we'll find a way to make shots
you know as long as our defense is there
we'll be fine thanks anthony